for the money he says that you know I'm
trying to make cash man so that'd be the
best way to do it but she's not healthy
it's give me an ass-whupping from Steve
Bay yeah or he connects cracked once
early on but even Francis connected with
steeper and steeper give a box that's
how freaky is yeah he's tough as [ __ ]
which is more more incredible even that
DC took them out so they're offering
steep a black beast you can tell they're
not even thinking DC steep a rebadged I
know DC's getting Jones Lesnar that's
that's it I don't think Lesnar's
fighting
I don't either I think some suspects
going on there I would be willing to bet
DC's last fight is that heavy weight
against John's against John Jones on
it's the biggest fight of all time
that's such a I like and I'm a Brock
Lesnar fan I like like I like when he
fights he's such a freak and celebrate
the guy I don't know fight let you some
hate Nowitzki go get a cup of coffee
when Brock fights I don't give a [ __ ]
but when when you talk about John Jones
DC that I mean no one's even talking
about Brock Jon Jones DC that's the
[ __ ] but I think that's bigger
than Conor could be - I think it's
there's so much history there it's for
[ __ ] the heavy and I think at DC at
heavyweight fight and John the the gap
narrows but that light heavyweight DC
it's not for you at heavyweight though
and I think that's why John's kind of
like I'll fight them has to be a light
heavyweight because DC does have some
advantage that heavyweight now but let's
let's look at what they've done with TJ
Dillashaw dropping him down to fly wait
why can't DC do the same thing when he
gets down the light-heavyweight what do
you mean oh saying what do you mean well
he struggles so hard to get down the
light heavyweight that it [ __ ] with his
cardio is conditioning he just doesn't
feel the same he says it takes too much
out of them he feels so much stronger at
heavyweight because he doesn't have to
go to that weight cut big dude man
naturally no no he's got body fat on him
got extra body fat that's not it doesn't
aid your performance now way doesn't
diminish himself or Zi mesomorph where
he's different because sometimes like a
fade or Noir or Roy Nelson
if though you should if you make those
guys shred it that's not in their DNA
they're not ectomorphs that's not you
can't do that but because we see guys
like
in Ghana we assume that you know I'm
saying like the ectomorph is the like
real skin super skinny mesomorph is what
you think that's in the middle that's
why I'm saying don't like I think DC's a
mesomorph and amorphous fat right yes
where I think for DC you like being
shredded his body doesn't function
awfully doesn't have to be shredded
but he's carrying around so much extra
weight like every watching dudes well he
starts really get look at Cain Velasquez
he's two guys he starts t pay who he
just connected with a beautiful shot in
the clinch that's a skill as wrestling I
think what's going on it heavyweight
with DC is he's not weakened let him eat
whatever the [ __ ] he wants and he's not
weakened I think that is critical for
him and I think when he gets done the
light heavyweight I think he's weakened
I think it takes something out of him
but I wonder how much they could
mitigate that with great diet and
planning it out the same way kala Vitas
done to teach it smaller guy naturally
in runners at 100% but still they leaned
him out further to get him down 135
pounds before the weight cut I just
don't think it's in DC's DNA to be that
leans just not for him maybe it's just
not you know maybe but I think everyone
benefits from scientific planning meal
planning real analysis of your calories
in calories out nutrients I don't know
maybe he does that works up some yeah
baby he does that some degree but some
guys I think do better where for a guy
like DC where he just that extra fat and
it just that's his thing I hope that
they fight if they do fight I hope the
first fight is a heavyweight that's 100%
because we've seen the light heavyweight
because they've talked about doing it at
light heavyweight they've seen the light
Johnson at light heavyweight yeah with
John Monson at light heavyweight so that
it never has to appear that he picked up
a title when they took it away from the
champion that they didn't earn it from
the champ and I get that but how great
would it be if you're John where you
know most people clearly know he beat DC
then you go to heavyweight and take that
from them it's just the ultimate [ __ ]
you but I also think DC is it
differently I'm a heavyweight has powers
if John does get hit and you see a
heavyweight could land some [ __ ] yeah
the debase not easy to knock out at all
no that would be the fight but it's also
like they get so emotional with each
other they get out yeah DC [ __ ] hates
that guy that's why pay-per-view goes
like that's what you want that's special
heavyweight yeah it's hard to sell a
trilogy at light heavyweight July July
4th that's at once we can ac/dc versus
John Jones the heavyweight championship
of the world champ champ champ champ
boom the giant pay-per-view three
million buys prior and there's a lot of
papers but yeah there's a lot of but it
could be done and that's what's gonna
happen
Dana's gonna make a offer they can't
refuse well we're in January February
March April May June July six months
from now you see you want to retire in
March I don't you know what it's like an
angel I he's not gonna retire and Mar
and that's he said he's forced what is
45 days gonna retire that's why it's t
pate tweet him was like dude let's do
this before you get out